en esta ocasión aprenderemos a usar este
de mónico hélice que es muy útil para el
análisis de circuitos de corriente
alterna en el análisis de sea o de
corriente alterna nos enfocamos o nos
limitamos con un tipo de señal que es la
senoidal y la cee lo ideal que nos gusta
más es el coche no es el coseno de omega
t más fi omega representa la frecuencia
en radiales de este coseno de aquí en
azul o mega es la frecuencia en radiales
y fi es el desplazamiento de fase si
vemos aquí está realmente no es una onda
coseno ya que el pico se encuentra un
poco antes del cero en lugar de estar
justo en el cero así que esta distancia
de aquí es el adelanto de fase esto es
que cuando fui es un número positivo
toda esta onda cose no va a estar
desplazada un poco hacia la izquierda a
esto nos referimos cuando decimos que
tiene un desplazamiento en la fase así
que cuando este tipo de señales están
dentro de nuestros componentes favoritos
vamos
tener una relación entre el voltaje y la
corriente en esos componentes esta
relación es la impedancia definimos la
idea de impedancia como la proporción de
el voltaje a la corriente y le dimos el
símbolo z y en este vídeo en lugar de
usar a ver cómo nuestra variable del
voltaje usaremos una letra diferente
vamos a usar el que representa a fm o
fuerza electromotriz y es muy común
usarla casi tan común como el voltaje
casi tan común como ve para representar
el voltaje y en un momento veremos por
qué estamos usando justamente esta letra
e otra manera en la que podemos escribir
esto es igual a z por iu y esto luce muy
parecido a la ley de ohm y lo que vamos
a encontrar es que vamos a poder aplicar
esto además de aplicarlo a resistencias
podemos aplicarlo a capacitores e
inductores primero veamos a nuestro
amigo el inductor y veamos la ecuación e
igual a z por y para un inductor
y voy a decir que es una senoidal así
que va a ser igual a cierta magnitud que
llamaremos y 0 que multiplica al coseno
de omega t más fin así que decimos que
nuestra corriente es una onda coseno con
esta magnitud y con este desplazamiento
de fase iii la tenemos dibujada aquí en
azul esto es si y ahora vamos a escribir
a él en términos de esta y de aquí es
igual a z ya que es igual z pues para un
inductor la impedancia es jota por omega
por l y que es y pues lo tenemos aquí
pero vamos a representar ahí de otra
manera vamos a representarla como un
software esto lo podemos representar
como a cero la magnitud de la corriente
con el ángulo fi estas son
representaciones equivalentes de y esta
es la representación en el dominio del
tiempo
esta es la representación en el dominio
del tiempo y esta es la representación
como factor y lo que tenemos aquí
enfrente de iu
factores escalar una j compleja que
veremos en un momento y tenemos a omega
el omega es la frecuencia y él es el
tamaño del inductor y para los
propósitos de este vídeo cuando gráfico
el voltaje aquí en anaranjado vamos a
suponer que el factor escalar omega l es
igual a 1 para poder enfocarnos en la
relación con el tiempo entre el voltaje
y la corriente cuando hablamos de
números complejos el multiplicar por
jota va a representar la rotación de 90
grados positivos así que puedo escribir
esto como igual escribimos primero
nuestro factor escalar omega l luego
escribimos y 0 que es la magnitud
original de nuestra corriente y aquí el
ángulo va a cambiar el ángulo es fin y
como esta multiplicación por jota
corresponde a sumar 90 grados
efe así que al multiplicar por jota
corresponde a sumar 90 grados al
desplazamiento en la fase si lo vemos
acá ahora esto es
y el desplazamiento en la fase
recordamos que habíamos dicho que esta
distancia de aquí era fi y ahora esta
distancia de acá va a ser fi más 90
grados tendremos un adelanto de fase de
90 grados y vean que aquí estoy
indicando la diferencia entre estos
picos ya que es más fácil para mí
observar así la distancia entre estas
dos ondas
así que si muevo esto hacia la izquierda
corresponde a un adelanto de fase de más
90 grados así que en un inductor que se
adelanta ahí
90 grados ahora veamos esto para un
capacitor haremos lo mismo para un
capacitor
aquí dibujamos nuestro capacitor y
hacemos lo mismo y aquí la corriente va
a ser igual a una magnitud y 0 por
coseno de omega t más fin y ahora veamos
cuál es el voltaje a través del
capacitor este voltaje a través del
capacitor que es lo mismo que tenemos
aquí es igual a z por y así que en el
capacitor es igual a z ya que es igual z
pues esta es la impedancia del capacitor
y es igual a 1 / j omega c&a la
corriente la vamos a representar igual
que como lo hicimos en el caso anterior
como factor la magnitud y 0 con un
ángulo fi ahora con cuidado hagamos esta
multiplicación que es igual a 1 entre
jota por uno entre omega c
por 0 con un ángulo fin y aquí tenemos
este término 1 / j y puedo reescribir
este 1 entre j
como menos j ahora multiplicamos algo
por menos jota y multiplicar por menos j
corresponde a tener una rotación de
menos 90 grados
así que escribimos e igual a 1 entre
omega c por 0 con un ángulo de fin y en
esta ocasión le vamos a restar 90 grados
y este menos de aquí corresponde a un
retraso en la fase aquí tenemos nuestra
corriente original y en azul y aquí
nuestro voltaje
en anaranjado y ahora lo que tenemos
aquí al medir esta diferencia vamos a
tener un retraso en la fase ya que está
apuntando hacia la derecha y el retraso
es de 90 grados esto es un retraso lo
podemos resumir como que en un
capacitor el voltaje se retrasa con
respecto de otra forma de decir esto
mismo es que se adelanta a 90 grados
recordemos que es el voltaje y
resaltamos estos resultados y aquí hay
muchos cambios de signo pero hay una
forma muy sencilla para recordar esto y
es aquí donde entra nuestro mnemonic o
hélice que nos dice hélice bueno hélice
nos dice que en un inductor l el voltaje
está adelante de la corriente y aquí si
tenemos un capacitor entonces la
corriente está adelante del voltaje y es
así como hélice nos ayuda a recordar el
orden que tienen el voltaje y la
corriente en inductores y capacitores
este de mónico nos va a ser útil mucho
tiempo